you guys i watched this whole series in
two days i was
hooked
is it true that mike flanagan has been
working on this particular series for 10
years
um yeah i think it's been since 2010.
yeah he told me that he was yeah it was
like originally a novel and then it was
a series and it's been all over the
place and um it's kind of one of his
babies which uh it's pretty cool to be a
part of it once he gets to make it
yeah so it's going to stay with you
zachary obviously getting into you know
the world of mike flanagan who we now
know and love as such an exciting voice
from
the horror genre what was the whole
process for you getting to work on a
show that has so many twists and turns
you know i i auditioned and then i got
the part and then i was just happy to be
here and
i
you know the work itself is pretty
intimidating when you look at the script
and it's you know paid along monologues
or two-page monologues
and
luckily
i
took it seriously and memorized my lines
because that is you know if you don't
know your lines especially when it's
like this you're not going to do good
work and
but if you do that you can do great work
and then you show up and you have seen
partners like kate and who are just
there and present and we have these
amazing sets and mike's such a
like a kind and giving director that it
was like really easy to just kind of
like be this character and just be
authentic to who he would be in these
moments
yeah did you do you know did you get a
heads up about all the twists and turns
are you reading the scripts being like
uh well i got to read them all before we
started shooting yeah yeah so you know
where it's going yeah exactly that's
awesome obviously kate we love your work
on hunting of hill house fly manor what
are you excited for fans of my plan
again to see when it comes to this
series
i think um people come to a flanagan
show expecting um
fully developed characters experiencing
horrific things you're not coming to the
flanigan show expecting a jump scare
every 30 seconds and so what i loved
about this show and i i think the fans
of the haunting of the hill house and
blind manor will love is character
development like deep people who you
care about and once you do they're put
in
extreme peril
and it's safe to say no one is safe on
this island
oh that's very safe to say
there's so many things i want to talk to
you guys about but obviously i don't
want to spoil anything but i think i
just you know
i have moments of like loving and not
loving so much father paul i mean wow
what a character what would you say his
character does to this island what what
does his arrival do
gosh i think it wakes up something in
everybody and not necessarily something
good but father paul
walks around and
yeah wakes up the subconscious of a lot
of people
are you gonna say zachary
no i was just gonna say i was gonna
speak more a little to just hamish as an
actor you know
i can't imagine anyone else doing that
part and uh he's just such a
unique individual
that
it needs to be that in order for this
father paul to work otherwise it's just
kind of this boring priest or someone
who's just giving sermons but he's such
an interesting like he doesn't do
anything the way you would expect no one
else would do it that way but it's so
genuine and i think that's even for
riley what draws him in is it's like oh
you're
like
you're a genuine person like i'm into
you and you believe this
but then riley's struggle is kind of but
i don't believe any of it so how can you
possibly believe it
yeah absolutely um so i was actually
talking to hamish and i said you know
with all the events that unfold on this
island which seemingly seems like a
beautiful place to live until it's not
very quickly um how would he handle all
the events on this island he thinks he
would be the superhero and he'd save
everyone harder
hamish is under one of those porches
curled up at a tiny ball
he's just oh i don't know what's going
on on the island i have to read my
shakespeare
no reluctant here we're there
how would you handle it
oh i'm off that island i am straight up
fairy god don't look back i am go on
girl enough times
amazing
what about you zachary oh me uh
yeah i'd gather my friends and family
and be like
you gotta go we gotta go let's go gotta
go we're going now no warning
guys congratulations on this series
honestly i binged this so hard so
congratulations it's great yeah thank
you